das ist eine Geschichte über Kleidung
über die Kleidung die wir tragen über
die Menschen die diese Kleidung
herstellen und über die Auswirkungen die
das alles auf unseren Planeten hat
es ist eine Geschichte über Gier und
Angst macht und Armut es ist sehr
komplex weil es sich über die ganze Welt
erstreckt aber es ist auch ganz einfach
weil es unsere Verbindung zu den
Menschen aufzeigt die mit Herz und
Händen hinter dem ganzen stehen
[Musik]
trieb in diese Geschichte hinein ohne
einen Funken Ahnung über Mode und fing
mit ein paar ganz einfachen Fragen an
was ich jedoch herausfand hat mein
Denken über die Kleidung die ich trage
für immer verändert und ich hoffe dass
es das gleiche bei dir bewirkt
[Musik]
am besten du beginnst mit deinem Namen
und erzählst wie alles anfing
ich heiße Lucy Siegel und ich bin
Journalistin und Moderatorin aus
Großbritannien und ich bin seit über
zehn Jahren förmlich besessen von den
umweltpolitischen und sozialen
Auswirkungen der Modeindustrie
ich liebe Kleidung einfach ich liebe
alles an ihr die Poesie den Stoff die
Farben das Gewebe sie sind unsere zweite
Reihe
hat the classic ich hatte natürlich auch
den klassischen riesigen Kleiderschrank
und beinahe täglich stopfte ich ihn mit
immer neuen Taschen und Klamotten voll
und trotzdem hatte ich nie etwas zum
Anziehen nie konnte ich ein passendes
Outfit zusammenstellen
wir kommunizieren unsere Identität
teilweise über unsere Kleidung das ist
geschichtlich gesehen nichts neues es
gibt ja die Trends am Hofe und Marie
Antoinette mit ihren riesigen hüten es
war schon immer eine sehr persönliche
Kommunikation in vielerlei Hinsicht und
genau das interessiert mich besonders
daran nämlich dass es ein fundamentaler
Teil davon ist was wir über uns zu
kommunizieren wünschen
in der Mode entwickelte sich eine Art
modenschausystem mit den
Vierjahreszeiten wie in der Natur und
lange Zeit lief es auch erstaunlich
präzise wie ein Urwerk doch heute kann
man das getrost aus dem Fenster werfen
denn es hat überhaupt nichts mehr mit
der heutigen Modeindustrie zu tun heute
gelten völlig neue Regeln
der Fokus verschiebt sich auf
skrupellose Weise von der Erschaffung
hin in eine Richtung die eigentlich nur
noch großen Geschäftsinteressen dient
luxafter Big Business interest
als Teenager machte ich mir eigentlich
nur Gedanken über den Preis der
Klamotten die ich kaufte entweder traf
ich meine Wahl nach Schnitt oder gutem
Angebot rückblickend bemerkte ich aber
das lange Zeit die meiste Kleidung hier
in Amerika produziert worden war in den
60ern stellten wir immer noch 95%
unserer Kleidung selbst her heute sind
es nur noch etwa 3% und die anderen 97%
werden in sämtliche Entwicklungsländer
ausgelagert
[Musik]
ich bin seit 9 Jahren im Modegeschäft
wir haben über 25.000 Beschäftigte
alleine in der
bekleidungsartikelproduktion und wir
produzieren eins von sechs Händen die in
den USA verkauft werden
[Musik]
wenn man in einen Laden geht und den
Richtpreis eine verkleidungsartikels mit
dem Preis von vor 20 Jahren vergleicht
wird man eine preisdeflation feststellen
das heißt der Preistrend ist
kontinuierlich gesunken doch sind auch
unsere Kosten gesunken ganz sicher nicht
im Gegenteil sie sind gestiegen
je mehr an Produktion wurde desto
niedriger wurde der Preis unserer
Kleidung dabei entstand ein völlig neues
Modell namens fast fashion schnelle Mode
das praktisch über Nacht die Art und
Weise wie Kleidung gehandelt wurde
veränderte
H&M Herzen von Manhattan ist der bisher
größte das Unternehmen und gerade mal
eine von vielen Filialen die im ganzen
Land geplant sind
[Musik]
Revolution fast fashion anstatt weil ja
haben wir jetzt praktisch 52 Saison im
Jahr das heißt jede Woche sehen wir
etwas Neues reinkommen und hat das
geschaffen damit sie im Grunde nur mehr
verkaufen können
[Musik]
diesen metallischen fransenrock gibt es
für 39 Dollar bei Joe fresh einem
brandneuen Laden in der Stadt mit
Preisschildern die wahrscheinlich noch
mehr preisbewusste Käufe ansprechen
werden amerikanische Kunden haben die
Rolle von H&M in der Mode wirklich
verstanden und wir wissen dass
amerikanische Kunden sehr wertorientiert
sind wenn man diese beiden
zusammenbringt also Mode und Wert dann
hat man das Erfolgsrezept dieser
japanische Textil Einzelhändler
verzeichnet in den USA einen gewaltigen
Erfolg
die Preise sind gefallen doch die
Herstellungsweise hat sich völlig
verändert und irgendwann fragt man sich
wo wird das alles auf
[Musik]
der globale Markt ist ein Ort an dem wir
Arbeit exportieren unter welchen
Bedingungen auch immer und anschließend
die Produkte zu mir zurückkommen und
zwar billig genug um sie bedenkenlos
wegwerfen zu können
globalisierte Produktion bedeutet im
Endeffekt dass die gesamte Herstellung
der Güter in niedrigkostenländer
ausgelagert wurde besonders dahin wo
Löhne sehr niedrig sind und auch niedrig
gehalten werden das bedeutet dass
diejenigen an der Spitze der
Wertschöpfungskette entscheiden können
wo die Produkte hergestellt werden dabei
können sie schön hin und her wechseln
wenn zum Beispiel eine Fabrik sagt dass
sie es nicht mehr so billig produzieren
können erwidert die Marke tja dann
beauftragen wir sie eben nicht mehr und
wechseln dahin wo wir es billiger
kriegen
in der West there using everydays die
Läden im Westen haben täglich
Niedrigpreise das heißt jeden Tag werde
ich von denen gedrückt und ich muss
meine Arbeiter drücken so läuft das die
Läden stehen im ständigen
Konkurrenzkampf und wenn Sie zu uns
kommen wegen einer Bestellung oder einer
Verhandlung heißt es der Laden XY
verkauft dieses Hemd für 5 Dollar also
muss ich es für 4 $ anbieten ihr müsst
es billiger herstellen also machen wir
das dann kommt eine andere Marke und
sagt hey die verkaufen ist für 4 $ dann
ist unser neuer sichtpreis 3 $ wenn ihr
jetzt auf 3 $ hinkriegt kommen wir ins
Geschäft ansonsten nicht weil wir die
Aufträge so dringend benötigen und keine
andere Option haben stimmen wir ihm zu
denn im Grunde versuchen wir nicht mehr
als zu überleben
so kann es nicht weitergehen entweder
steigt der Preis der Produkte oder
Hersteller müssen schließen bzw an allen
Ecken und Enden einsparen an allen Ecken
und Enden zu sparen und sogar
Sicherheitsvorschriften zu missachten
wurde in diesem neuen Geschäftsmodell zu
allgemein akzeptierten Norm bis eines
April morgens ein schrecklicher Vorfall
in Bangladesch die Schattenseite der
Modeindustrie auf die Titel Seiten
brachte staatlichen Medienberichten
zufolge stürzt ein achtstöckiges Gebäude
in der Nähe von Bergheim bei dem mehr
als 70 Menschen ums Leben kamen
[Applaus]
wenn man
anziehen
Rettungskräfte stehen im Wettlauf mit
der Zeit in den Trümmern suchen sie
verzweifelt nach Überlebenden
Tod hunderte noch lebendig begraben
Behörden in Bangladesch berichten dass
die fabrikinhaber eine
Evakuierungsanordnung ignorierten
etwa 400 Tote
hunderte Fabrikarbeiter in Bangladesch
zahlen den hohen Preis billiger Kleidung
eine riesige Menschenmenge hat sich in
der Nähe des Gebäudes versammelt unter
ihnen viele Familienmitglieder die nach
ihren Angehörigen suchen und sie
berichten dass sie noch immer Hilfe
Schreier aus dem trümern hören doch
viele verlieren langsam die Hoffnung
Arbeitsplatz in Richtung Treppenhaus
als ich es erreichte fiel das Gebäude
zusammen und meine Beine wurden
eingeklemmt
noch die Seitenwand auf meine Beine
mir wurde klar dass ich meine Beine dann
nicht mehr rausbekommen und gab auf
sich Gedanken rasten mir durch den Kopf
nicht mal weinen konnte ich
aber keinen müssen anybody jeder der wie
ich über die Probleme in der
belieferungskette geschrieben hat
insbesondere bei fast fashion versuchte
vor allem klar zu machen von wem das
höchste Risiko tatsächlich getragen wird
nämlich von denen die am stärksten
gefährdet sind und am schlechtesten
bezahlt werden ant du hast paid man hat
immer wieder versucht es zu
verdeutlichen aber ich hätte nie gedacht
dass die Darstellung von dem was man zu
vermitteln versucht so katastrophal ist
und seiner Plaza war für mich wie eine
regelrechte Horrorgeschichte
zwei Wochen nach der Katastrophe und
einer niederschmetternden Opferzahl von
derzeit 931 kann man vom schwersten
Unglück in der Modeindustrie aller
Zeiten sprechen
ich glaube dass eines der zu tiefst
beeindruckenden Dinge des Runner Plaza
Unglücks die Nachricht darüber war dass
die Arbeiter die Missstände des Gebäudes
dem Management bereits gemeldet hatten
sie hatten längst darauf hingewiesen
dass das Fundament des Mauerwerks
unsicher war und dennoch wurden sie
gezwungen wieder reinzugehen
viele der Überlebenden fragen wieso sie
zur Arbeit gezwungen wurden obwohl das
Management bereits sowohl über den
maroden Zustand des Gebäudes Bescheid
wusste als auch über die Bedenken der
Arbeiter am Tag des Einsturzes sehr viel
Kleidung in amerikanischen Geschäften
wird in Bangladesch von Arbeitern
hergestellt die im Schnitt zwei Dollar
am Tag verdienen letzte Monat stürzte
eine Textilfabrik ein und riss mehr als
1000 Menschen in den Tod einige Monate
zuvor tötete einen Fabrik Brand mehr als
100 Menschen und während die Leichen und
Körper aus den Trümmern geborgen wurden
fängt heute früh eine Fabrik in
Bangladesch Feuer und forderte acht
Todesopfer
als sich die unglücksberichte häuften
wurde es zu einer unumstößlichen
Tatsache dass sich drei der vier
schlimmsten Tragödien der Modegeschichte
alle in einem Jahr ereignet hatten so
wie die Zahl der Todesopfer weiter
anstieg so stiegen auch die Profite
weiter an das Jahr nach dem Runner Plaza
Unglück war für die Bekleidungsindustrie
das profitabelste Jahr aller Zeiten die
globale Modeindustrie erwirtschafteten
und fast 3 Billionen Dollar im Jahr
Bangladesch ist jetzt der zweitgrößte
textilexporteur nach China wie das im
Gegensatz zu einigen seiner Konkurrenten
bleibt die Produktion in bangladeshorts
billig und Gewerkschaften haben nur
begrenzten Einfluss das Land ist am
absoluten Ende der Wertschöpfungskette
angelangt
diese 1000 armen Menschen verloren ihr
Leben weil niemand sich um sie kümmerte
oder einen feuchten dreckscherte sie
wollen nur den billigsten Preis und den
Besten gewinnen so sollte es nicht sein
jeder sollte die Verantwortung für diese
Kinder tragen
doch es ist wie es ist
es tut mir leid aber es ist nicht nur
der Preisdruck
des Lebens anderer zu tun das ist
einfach nicht richtig
wir sind doch schließlich im 21
Jahrhundert in einer globalisierten Welt
und wir lassen das Leben anderer einfach
so links liegen wie kann das sein
Name wieso ist diese gigantische und
raffgierige Industrie die so viele
Gewinne für so wenige Menschen generiert
und fähig Millionen ihre Arbeiter
ordnungsgemäß und angemessen zu
entlohnen warum ist sie nicht imstande
deren Sicherheit zu gewährleisten wir
sprechen hier von grundlegenden
Menschenrechten wieso ist sie nicht in
der Lage diese Dinge zu leisten während
sie solche schwindelerregenden Profite
erwirtschaftet liegt es daran dass sie
nicht richtig funktioniert das ist meine
Frage
Lucys Frage klingt offensichtlich doch
anstatt dass sie beantwortet wurde traf
ich überall auf Menschen die immer zu
versuchten die Preise zu rechtfertigen
und die wirtschaftlichen Vorteile zu
verteidigen diese Niedriglohn Ausbeuter
Betriebe sogenannte Sweatshops sind
nicht die schlechteste Option die die
Arbeiter heutzutage haben sie sind Teil
eines Prozesses der die Lebensstandards
und Löhne steigert und im Laufe der Zeit
auch zu besseren Arbeitskonditionen
führt
unmittelbarer Entwicklungsfaktoren sind
physisches Kapital Technologie und
Humankapital also die Fertigkeiten der
Arbeiter dieses Sweatshops bringen den
Arbeitern diese drei Faktoren und setzen
diesen prozessengang
könnte es sein dass dieses Webshops
eigentlich gut sind ja genau
schreckliche ausbeuterbetriebe allein
dieser Begriff ruft furchtbare Bilder
von armen Menschen und leidenden Kindern
hervor die unter widrigsten Bedingungen
die Kleider für uns selbst Süchtigen
Amerikaner herstellen und vielen Dank
auch hierfür
das
beunruhigt es mich dass Menschen in
Fabriken arbeiten und Kleidung für
Amerikaner oder Europäer herstellen oder
dass sie auf diese Weise ihre Leben
verbringen ist es das wonach Sie mich
fragen
ja genau
nein sie verrichten einfach nur eine
Arbeit es gibt weitaus schlimmere Dinge
die Sie tun könnten
wir sind live und ich würde Sie bitten
Ausbeuter Betriebe zu definieren wir
reden hier von Städten mit sehr
schlechten Arbeitsbedingungen die der
Durchschnitts Amerikaner folgendermaßen
sieht niedrige Löhne gemäß unserem
Standard vielleicht auch
kinderarbeitsplätze die mit dem lokalen
Arbeitsrecht nicht konform sind aber es
gibt andere Kernelemente dieser Modelle
die ich gern ansprechen nämlich dass es
auch Orte gibt an denen Menschen sich
aussuchen können zu arbeiten zugegeben
die Auswahl anderer Optionen ist nicht
gerade toll es gibt ja eigentlich nichts
wirklich gefährliches an der Näharbeit
an sich wir befinden uns also in einer
relativ ungefährlichen Industrie nicht
wie beim Bergbau oder in der
Erdgasförderung oder in vielen anderen
Bereichen die wesentlich gefährlicher
sind natürlich sehen Jobs für jeden
Westler der wohlhabend genug ist Ihr
Video anzugucken erstmal nach
furchtbaren Arbeitsbedingungen und
Dumpinglöhnen aus aber wir müssen dabei
auch bedenken dass die vorhandenen
Alternativen dieser Arbeiter nicht
unsere Alternativen sind sie sind
weitaus schlechter als unsere und
meisten sogar noch viel schlechter als
der Fabrik Job den der Arbeit hat
niedrige Löhne unsichere
Arbeitsbedingungen und Fabrik Unglücke
werden alle mit dem Argument
entschuldigt dass diese Jobs für
Menschen ohne Alternativen dringend
benötigt werden diese Geschichte wird
immer wieder aufgetisch sobald es darum
geht das globale Vorgehen der
Modeindustrie zu rechtfertigen
aber es gibt auch diejenigen die glauben
dass es einen besseren Weg geben muss
mit Kleidung zu handeln sie zu
produzieren und mit ihr
Wirtschaftswachstum zu erzielen
wir wissen also noch nicht wie lange
diese Stickarbeit dauern wird könntest
du nicht Santo fragen wie lange die
ganze Stoffbahn grob brauchen könnte wir
wollen es ja später in der Aufstellung
sehen und da wäre es toll das zu wissen
ich bin Safia
von People Tree People Tree ist eine
fairtrade-modemarke die vor über 20
Jahren in Japan ins Leben gerufen wurde
du hast dir Sorgen gemacht dass wir
vielleicht so viel marineblau haben was
denkst du jetzt wir haben in der
Sommersaison 14 viel schwarz verwendet
was mit orlas Kooperation sehr gut
funktioniert haben wir genug
schwarz-drucke in der Kollektion
wir haben den vorlagenabdruck in schwarz
verloren aber ich glaube dieser
rosafarbene Abdruck mit dem sich jeder
so schwer tut wird sich gut verkaufen
ich glaube dass die meisten Modemarken
mit einem kollektions- oder look-konzept
anfangen sie denken eher nicht daran wie
es am Ende herstellen wird oder wie man
sicherstellen kann dass die Hersteller
auch etwas zu essen haben was wir bei
People Tree versuchen ist zuerst die
Fertigkeiten jeder einzelnen
produktionsgruppe zu bündeln und dann
die Kollektion zu entwerfen ohne dabei
die Ganzheitlichkeit und Ästhetik der
Kollektion aus dem Auge zu verlieren
denn seine klatschen
ich habe ursprünglich mit
freiberuflichen Designern gearbeitet und
ich bin oft noch Bangladesch Simbabwe
Indien Nepal und zu den Philippinen
gereist Stück für Stück haben wir uns
ein großartiges Netzwerk mit
Gleichgesinnten fairtrade-organisationen
aufgebaut die die Entwicklung der Frauen
als auch der sozialen Umgebung der
Arbeiter als absolut notwendig ansehen
[Musik]
heute ist der 15 Jahrestag dieser world
Fairtrade Veranstaltung wir organisieren
diese Art von Veranstaltungen in über 60
Ländern und je nach Land sind zwischen
10 und 60 verschiedene Organisationen
mit an Bord heute finden parallel wie
wir es auch hier machen Modeschauen und
Seminare in über 3000 Orten auf der
ganzen Welt statt Arno Tabelle
[Musik]
könntest du dich etwas mehr zu mir
drehen
das ist wunderschön
ist die bürgerliche Antwort auf soziale
Ungerechtigkeit in einem internationalen
Handelssystem das mehrheitlich völlig
gestört ist bei dem Arbeitern und Bauern
kein Existenzminimum gezahlt wird und
die Produktionsbedingungen der Güter die
wir täglich kaufen überhaupt nicht
beachtet werden
[Musik]
ich heiße Chima und ich bin 23 Jahre alt
ich war 12 als ich noch da kam
[Musik]
Shima ist eine von 40 Millionen
textilarbeitern auf der ganzen Welt fast
vier Millionen dieser Arbeiter leben
hier in Bangladesch und arbeiten in fast
5000 Fabriken in denen sie die Kleidung
für marktführende westliche Modelabels
herstellen über 85% dieser Arbeiter sind
Frauen und der Mindestlohn beträgt
weniger als 3 $ am Tag sie gehören zu
den am niedrigsten bezahlten
textilarbeitern der Welt ich wohnte
zuerst mal bei meiner Tante als ich zum
ersten Mal in einer Textilfabrik zu
arbeiten begann lag mein Lohn seit 10 $
im Monat
[Musik]
meine Tochter die heißt Nadja Akte
an manchen Tagen nehme ich sie mit in
die Fabrik aber es ist furchtbar heiß
dort und überall gibt es Chemikalien die
für Kinder sehr schädlich sind
langfristig kann sie nicht bei mir jeden
Tag bleiben weil es niemanden gibt der
sich um sie kümmert
[Musik]
die Arbeiter dürfen keinerlei Misstrauen
in den Fabrikbesitzer haben wenn sie
dennoch misstrauisch sind kann keine
gute Arbeitsatmosphäre der Fabrik
entstehen sie müssen also Respekt haben
weil der Besitzer sie gemäß der
Vereinbarung bezahlt wenn Sie diese Art
von Vertrauen nicht aufbringen erhält
man nicht das gewünschte Resultat
ich habe eine Gewerkschaft gegründet in
der ich seit Anbeginn die Präsidentin
bin
wir haben mal eine Liste mit Ansprüchen
eingereicht und die Manager haben sie
auch gelesen
darauf folgend gab es heftige
Auseinandersetzungen mit den Managern
im Anschluss schlossen sie die Türen und
zusammen mit 30 oder 40 Angestellten
griffen uns die Manager an und schlugen
auf uns ein
sie nahmen alles Stühle Stöcke
stoffwagen aber auch scheren um auf uns
einzuprügeln
sie schleuderten sogar unsere Köpfe
gegen die Wände und schlugen und traten
uns in Brust und Unterleib
es wird angenommen dass jeder sechste
auf der Welt in irgendeinem Teil der
globalen Modeindustrie tätig ist was sie
zur größten arbeitsabhängigen Industrie
der Welt macht
die meiste Arbeit wird von Menschen wie
China gemacht Menschen ohne Stimme in
der größten Wertschöpfungskette der
Geschichte aber um die Auswirkungen zu
verstehen die die Modeindustrie auf uns
hat müssen wir dahin zurückkehren wo
alles seinen Anfang nahm
meine Großeltern siedelten sich in den
20er Jahren hier an das ist also ein
Teil meiner Herkunft und die Leute
werden nicht müde zu fragen wieso ich
Bio baumwoll-pharmerin bin mein Opa war
in Deutschland Landwirt der der festen
Ansicht war dass man das Land und das
Leben darauf respektieren muss
wir befinden uns hier in der Hochebene
von Texas und in dieser Region wächst
Baumwolle auf einer Fläche von etwa
12.000 Quadratkilometern wir sind
praktisch das größte baumwollgebiet der
Welt in nur zehn Jahren wurden 80% davon
zu genetisch veränderter Baumwolle das
meiste davon ist Roundup Ready das heißt
anstatt dass die Landwirte oder
saisonale Arbeiter hier und da das
Unkraut entfernen werden die Felder nun
vollständig gespritzt ist
Baumwolle produziert die Faser die
heutzutage in der meisten Kleidung
Verwendung findet und weil unser Appetit
auf Mode immer weiter anwächst wird die
Baumwollpflanze weiterentwickelt um
mithalten zu können es ist besser es gab
eine enorme Kampagne für die
Industrialisierung der Landwirtschaft
also zur Intensivierung der
Landwirtschaft
an die Stelle der alten Anbaumethoden
die sehr stark auf die Natur und die
jahreszeitlichen Zyklen abgestimmt waren
heute sehen wir eine Intensivierung bei
der das Land fast gleichwertig wie eine
Fabrik be
es wurde eine Vorgehensweise geschaffen
die Millionen von Landflächen einfach
gleich behandelt wir kippen einfach eine
Ladung Chemikalien drüber am Ende
kriegen wir massive ökologische
Nebenwirkungen von denen keiner Ahnung
hat was da wirklich passiert die Natur
heilt sich bekanntlich selbst aber nur
in kleinen Einheiten doch wenn wir mit
dieser riesengroßen Methode da ankommen
dann können wir doch nicht wirklich
wissen was tatsächlich passieren könnte
wir sehen keine wirkliche Reduzierung
der Pestizide davon ist zwar auf die
Rede aber doch nicht in unserer Gegend
in der aber Millionen Quadratmeter
deshalb Planes mit äußerst teuren
Roundup werden welchen Einfluss hat das
auf unseren Boden der durch die
Rückstände in einem mikrobiotisch dieser
strösen Zustand hinterlassen wird welche
Auswirkungen hat das auf die Menschen in
unseren Gemeinden wo werden die Kosten
dafür abgebildet
ist stolz darauf industrieführend in
landwirtschaftlichen Innovationen zu
sein denn diese Fortschritte können
Ihnen dabei helfen die Erträge für die
zukünftigen Bedürfnisse der Welt zu
verdoppeln wir geben uns der Zukunft der
Landwirtschaft hin und versorgen
Landwirte mit Innovationen die Ihnen
helfen mehr zu produzieren und mehr zu
erhalten während das Leben der Menschen
auf der ganzen Welt verbessert wird
zusammen packen wir die
Herausforderungen der nächsten
Generation an und darüber hinaus
[Musik]
nach den Kriegen standen überall diese
leeren Fabriken in denen die
kriegsemikalien und Sprengstoffe
produziert worden waren
die westlichen Länder meinten dass es
eine gute Idee sei sie an die Dritte
Welt zu vermarkten schließlich
produziert dieselbe Industrie die
Sprengstoffe herstellt auch
stickstoffdüngemittel
also fingen sie in den 1950er Jahren an
nachdem wir unabhängig geworden waren
auf den Markt zu drängen
doch die stickstoffdüngemittel vertragen
sich nicht gut mit den heimischen
Nutzpflanzen was an lagerungsproblemen
liegt daraufhin reorganisierte sich das
ganze System um die Pflanze zu
modifizieren damit sie mehr Pestizide
vertragen konnte
BT Baumwolle ist eine Baumwolle bei der
Eingehen einer Bakterie hinzugefügt
worden ist um ein Gift zu produzieren
aber die Bt-Baumwolle die offenbar
Schädlinge abwehren kann wurde
eigentlich nur deswegen angeboten weil
es ein Ungeheuer einfacher Weg für die
Konzerne ist das Saatgut zu besitzen
durch die Patentierung dieser genetisch
modifizierten Pflanzen konnte man cento
zu einem der größten Saatgut und
Chemiekonzern der Geschichte werden ich
wollte unbedingt mit jemandem sprechen
der bereits dort gearbeitet hatte und
ich erfuhr dass ein ehemaliger
Geschäftsführer für Indien dafür bereit
war ein guter Freund von mir der in der
Forschung war arbeitete an diesem
modifizierten Nutzpflanzen er kam zu mir
ins Hotel auf einen Drink und nach ein
paar Gläsern erzählte er mir dann hey
Jack die Art und Weise wie du Geschäfte
in Indien machst wird sich komplett
verändern ich fragte ihn was das
bedeutet er sagte wir steigen in das
saatgutgeschäft ein und das heißt es
soll für alle Nutzpflanzen gelten so
dass wir ein Monopol aufsaatgut haben
jeder Bauer muss dann zu uns kommen und
jedes Mal neues Saatgut kaufen sofort
schrillten die Alarmglocken in mir auf
wenn ein armer Landwirt zu Monsanto
gehen muss um jedes Mal sein Saatgut zu
kaufen und zwar sehr teures Saatgut wie
wird es dann mit der BT Baumwolle damals
wussten wir noch gar nichts von
genetisch modifiziertem Saatgut ein
Monopol Auffahrt gut ist etwas sehr
schlechtes Bauern müssen sich wegen der
enormen Kosten von über 17.000% über
ihrem Einkommen extrem hoch verschulden
um das dagegen doch die angebliche
sichere pflanzenresistenz hält nicht was
sie verspricht so dass sie mehr
Pestizide kaufen
ökologisches Rauschgift je mehr man sie
einsetzt desto mehr braucht man sie für
eine gewisse Zeit steigt der Gewinn des
Einzelnen Erzeugnisses doch dann sagt er
wieder ab weil der Boden verseucht
worden ist
der Großteil von Indiens Baumwolle
wächst in der ponchupregion die sehr
schnell zum größten Benutzer von
Pestiziden wurde
dr prepaising hat die Auswirkungen
dieser Chemikalien auf die menschliche
Gesundheit untersucht und seine Berichte
weisen auf eine dramatische Zahl an
Geburtsfehlern Krebs und
Geisteskrankheiten in dieser Region hin
man kann in jedem Dorf hunderte
krebskranke Menschen sehen 70 bis 80
Kinder in jedem Dorf kämpfen mit
geistigen oder körperlichen
Behinderungen
[Musik]
alle Unternehmen die Düngemittel und
Pestizide herstellen streiten diese
Nachwirkungen vehement ab und hier sehen
Sie ein typisches Symptom ihrer
Toxizität ein Dorf hat im Schnitt 60
geistig behinderte Kinder wie diesen
jungen hier es ist ein wirklich
gefährliches Phänomen in punjab-gebiet
all die armen Menschen Arbeiter
Landwirte und Kleinbauern sind hier
schon längst am Limit angekommen so dass
sie sich keine Behandlung mehr leisten
können eine Leben
im Grunde haben sie sich schon längst
mit dem Tod ihre Kinder abgefunden und
warten nur noch darauf dass er kommt wie
diese Mutter hier
sind zwei
die Unternehmen die das genmanipulierte
Saatgut herstellen sind dieselben wie
die die Chemikalien herstellen aber auch
die Medikamente die sie jetzt
patentieren lassen wenn man also Krebs
bekommt werden noch mehr Gewinne
generiert für die ist es eine
aufwärtsdrehende gewinnspirale für die
Menschen und die Natur eine
abwärtsdrehende verlustspirale eines
Tages kommen dann die Vertreter dieser
Unternehmen und sagen zu den Bauern du
schuldest mir Betrag X doch du hast
nicht gezeigt also gehört dein Land
jetzt mir an diesem Tag geht der Bauer
raus aufs Feld und trinkt eine dieser
Flaschen mit dem Pestiziden jede Witwe
mit der sprach sagte mir dann kamen die
Nachbarn und sagten dass sie meinen Mann
im Feld liegen sah ich bin
in den letzten 16 Jahren gab es über
250.000 erfasste selbstmordfälle von
Landwirten in Indien
das entspricht etwa einem Pharma alle 30
Minuten und es ist die größte erfasste
Selbstmordrate in der Geschichte
[Musik]
ihr klarer die Auswirkungen der
Modeindustrie für unsere Welt werden
desto stärker steigt die Zahl an
forschungsbeiträgen die aufzeigen dass
sie genauso Auswirkungen auf uns hat den
Konsumenten dieser Kleidung
robinar heute also 20 Jahre und 100
Studien später wissen wir dass je mehr
Menschen ihren Schwerpunkt auf
materialistische Werte legen desto
wichtiger erscheinen für Sie Geld Image
Status und Besitz zu sein und desto
unglücklicher deprimierter und
verängstlichter werden Sie
wissen dass all diese psychologischen
Probleme mit dem Anstieg materieller
Werte ebenfalls mit ansteigen allerdings
steht das im totalen Widerspruch mit den
abertausenden Werbebotschaften die jeden
Tag auf uns einwirken und suggerieren
wollen dass Materialismus unterstreben
nach Besitz und glücklicher machen
das ist wichtig zu verstehen dass
Werbung eine Form bzw Strategie der
Propaganda ist wir sehen Propaganda als
etwas düsteres und totalitäres
Lautsprecher singende Menschenmassen und
so weiter wir denken sofort an Hitler
und stellen es uns als etwas
ausländisches vor doch in Wirklichkeit
ist es so typisch amerikanisch wie ein
Hamburger
[Musik]
der Grund wieso Werbung funktioniert ist
dass die schlauen Werbefachleute
zumindest versuchen eine Botschaft
anzuhängen die uns suggeriert dass
unsere Bedürfnisse nur durch den Kauf
dieses Produktes befriedigt werden kann
es will dir glauben machen dass du
wunderschön in diesem Teil aussiehst
doch wenn du es anziehst siehst du oft
zu dick oder nicht ganz so gut darin aus
und dann tut es dir leid es gekauft zu
haben dann kaufst du eben ein anderes
[Musik]
man muss mal nur an die Auto Reklame
denken die einem vermittelt dass man es
mit diesem Auto zu was gebracht hat oder
sogar zu einer besseren Person wird weil
man jetzt diesen BMW oder Audi fährt
oder die ganzen Shampoo Werbungen in
denen die Person am Ende schönes
glänzendes Haar hat beliebt ist und von
ihrem Umfeld geschätzt wird die
fundamentale Botschaft ist immer
dieselbe deine Probleme im Leben werden
nur durch Konsum gelöst the way is all
in your life ist Samsung
[Musik]
ich versuche zu verstehen warum Menschen
nicht realisieren dass sie eigentlich
immer ärmer werden und ich frage mich
was ich verändert haben könnte im
Vergleich zu meiner Jugend die Mode ist
etwas das sich drastisch verändert hat
ich konnte mir ein zwei oder auch mal
vier T-Shirts im Jahr leisten doch jetzt
kaufen meine Kinder für jede Party ein
neues t-shirty Party
es war alles Gute so verstand ich das
fast fashion etwas völlig Neues ist
falls es ihm nicht aufgefallen ist der
Preis ist in den letzten Jahren gesunken
etwas vom zunehmenden Verschwinden der
Mittelklasse kommt doch die Dinge die
Menschen wirklich brauchen sind sehr
kostenintensiv so wie ein Haus ein
Studium oder eine Lebensversicherung
andererseits ist eine Art Quelle des
Trostes ein fester Bestandteil unseres
Lebens geworden ich kann mir ein oder
zwei T-Shirts pro Party kaufen sogar pro
Tag und das obwohl ich sehr arm bin und
die Dinge verloren habe nicht wirklich
brauche
heutzutage kaufen wir über 80 Milliarden
neue Kleidungsstücke pro Jahr das sind
400% mehr als wir uns noch vor zwei
Jahrzehnten kauften die Art und Weise
wie wir Kleidung konsumieren hat sich so
stark und so schnell verändert dass
einige Menschen einen Schritt zurück
traten um zu versuchen den Ursprung
dieses neuen Modells und die
Konsequenzen einer solchen noch nie da
gewesenen konsumsteigerung zu verstehen
es gab mal einen Artikel im seinerzeit
führenden werbemagazin printers ink von
einem renommierten Werbetexter namens
Ernest Elmo cookins einem sehr
bedeutenden Mann in der Kunst des
werbetextens heißen dieser Beitrag trug
den Titel Konsumismus und besagte dass
es zwei verschiedene Arten von Produkten
gibt die einen die man gebraucht so wie
Waschmaschinen Autos und so weiter Dinge
die man sich langfristig anschafft und
die anderen die man verbraucht Kaugummis
Zigaretten und andere kurzlebige
Konsumgüter
er schrieb dass es beim Konsumismus
einzig darum gehe die Menschen dazu zu
bringen Gebrauchsgüter wie
Verbrauchsgüter zu behandeln
mit der innovativen Verkaufspolitik drei
zum Preis von einem ist ein Anzug von
Joseph ey Bank sogar billiger als eine
Küchenrolle und jetzt gibt es sie sogar
in diesem praktischen Spendern mit vier
Anzügen zum Preis eines einfachen
Abendessens habe ich kein schlechtes
Gewissen mehr sie wegzuwerfen wenn ich
fertig bin
[Musik]
man muss sich nur mal die Mülldeponien
ansehen die Menge an Textilien die
weggeworfen werden ist in den letzten
zehn Jahren stetig angestiegen und das
wirft natürlich ein schlechtes Licht auf
die fast fashionindustrieindustrie
[Musik]
weiter wie unsere Spezies dekadieren und
unsere letzten übrig gebliebenen
ursprünglichen Instinkte praktisch
wegwerfen desto entschlossener sind wir
immer mehr Wegwerfartikel zu produzieren
das macht einfach keinen Sinn Kleidung
sollte nicht und kann nicht einfach als
Wegwerfprodukt gesehen werden also des
Bösen
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist nach jedem großen
industriellen Wandel ist mal sehr lange
dauert bis man den Dreck einer
verschmutzenden Sache riechen und sehen
kann und ich denke das jetzt wieder eine
Wende stattfindet weil man einfach nicht
mehr verleugnen kann dass die fast
Fashion-Industrie massiv in negative
Auswirkungen auf die Entwicklungsländer
haben
der Durchschnitts Amerikaner wird etwa
37 Kilo an textilabfällen Weg pro Jahr
das bedeutet mehr als 11 Millionen
Tonnen an textilabfällen alleine in den
USA das meiste davon ist nicht
biologisch abbaubar was bedeutet dass
sie für die nächsten 200 Jahre oder
länger auf den Deponien bleiben werden
während sie Schadstoffe ausstoßen ein
riesiger Teil davon ist sie Kleidung und
viele Menschen glauben dass sie was
Gutes damit tun Kleidung zu spenden die
Reise allein eines T-Shirts das an eine
Hilfsorganisation gespendet wird ist
absurd und widerwärtig an
PPP ist eine wahre Krankheit in Haiti
und nicht nur in Haiti sondern in
praktisch jedem Entwicklungsland kann
man sagen es ist ein gewaltiges Problem
Kleidung das meiste aus den Staaten die
Menschen kommen und kaufen kistenweise
die Kleidung und wissen nicht mal was
sie kaufen das ist Kleidung die an
Hilfsorganisationen gespendet worden ist
und in den Secondhandläden der
Organisation nicht verkauft wird sie
wird verpackt und in die dritte
weltländer verschickt und das meiste
landet dann hier
nur 10% der Kleidung die wir spenden
wird in Secondhandläden bei uns verkauft
und je schneller wir uns umziehen desto
mehr wird in Entwicklungsländer wie
Haiti ausrangiert durch die steigende
Menge der Secondhand-Kleidung in Haiti
ist die lokale Textilindustrie praktisch
verschwunden
einstmals gab es hier einen stolzen
schneiderei-zweig heute produziert er
überwiegend billig T-Shirts für den
Export nach Amerika
das geht früher als man dort noch
gearbeitet hat hat man ständig neue
Leute gesehen sie hatten den Wunsch und
die Hoffnung dass Näherei Handwerk zu
lernen vielen wurde es beigebracht und
dadurch gewannen sie die Zuversicht mit
diesen Fähigkeiten einen guten Job zu
finden heutzutage wird einem zwar noch
gezeigt wie man näht aber die Chancen
davon leben zu können sind praktisch
hoffnungslos ne die Barsche
ich sage den Leuten ständig dass es
nicht gutes Dinge zu kaufen weil sie nur
zehn Dollar kosten heute wenn man in
eine Bar geht oder so kocht man sich
vorher ein Kleid für zehn Dollar weil es
so billig ist denkt man schon gar nicht
mehr darüber nach und wenn es nicht mehr
gefällt wirft man es weg und man macht
dasselbe immer und immer wieder
während das Bewusstsein über den
Einfluss der Mode auf unsere Welt wächst
fangen industriefachleute an die
Auswirkungen eines auf fahrlässiger
Produktion und auf endlosen
konsumbasierenden Konzeptes zu
hinterfragen
wir bei Patagonia hassen den Begriff
Verbraucher es muss ein besseres Wort
geben mir bevorzugen eher Kunden und
zwar solche Kunden die den Einfluss
ihres Konsums erkannt haben nämlich dass
sie als Konsumenten auch Teil des
Problems sind wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir unsere Kunden
dazu ermutigen sich uns beim
Hinterfragen des Konsums anzuschließen
denn ohne reale Reduzierung des Konsums
haben wir nicht das Gefühl eine
kollektive Lösung für die anstehenden
Probleme zu finden nämlich dem
fortschreitenden Rückgang der Gesundheit
unseres Planeten
die Modeindustrie muss hier eigentlich
nur anfangen ihre Arbeitsweise zu
überdenken und die konventionellen
Formen in Frage stellen für mich als
Modedesignerin ist dies das aufregendste
im Moment viel aufregender als die
Farben der Saison auszusuchen oder
Schnitte und Rocklängen festzulegen ich
finde es in meiner Branche viel
herausfordernder zu sagen ich werde es
diesmal auf eine umweltschonende Art
versuchen
hat durch die Werbung der Gesellschaft
eingeredet das Glückseligkeit in Dingen
liegt und das wahre Glückseligkeit nur
durch die jährlichen saisonalen
wöchentlichen täglichen Erwerb von immer
mehr Dingen erreicht werden kann wir
wollen unsere Kunden dazu anregen genau
über diese Suggestionen nachzudenken um
zu verstehen woher sie kommen und durch
dieses Verständnis können wir alle
zusammen diesen Prozess verändern
[Musik]
die Kunden müssen lernen dass sie
diejenigen sind die die Verantwortung
tragen ohne sie sind für arbeitslos und
das ist äußerst wichtig man ist
überhaupt nicht verpflichtet daran zu
glauben wenn es einem nicht gefällt
alles liebe diese Sticker
ja sie ist wirklich sehr schön findest
du nicht dass wir die Stickerei auf
beiden Seiten machen sollten ich finde
wir müssten sie auch hier anbringen es
sieht irgendwie geizig aus wenn sie nur
vorne ist machen wir es doch auf beide
Seiten das wird nicht viel mehr kosten
oder
ist ein Fairtrade Mode-Unternehmen aber
auch eine Art Entwicklungsgesellschaft
sie hilft über 3000 Menschen in diesem
Dorf peopleage
ich komme etwa alle vier Monate her wir
nennen das produktionstrips und wir
arbeiten mit den Erzeugern zusammen um
herauszufinden was die Hindernisse sind
um ein großartiges Produkt herzustellen
und um es richtig zu vermarkten wir
betreiben zudem auch Hilfe zur
Selbsthilfe und schauen uns auch hier
die Hindernisse an um mehr
Sozialleistungen zu fördern und um den
Umweltschutz in diesem Gebiet zu
verbessern für mich geht es hier um
Partnerschaft und um eine gemeinsame
Erarbeitung von kreativen Lösungen mit
dem ganzen Team Probleme zu erkennen und
einen Weg zu finden der für alle
funktioniert
ich möchte den besten Mitarbeiter und
eine weibliche Repräsentantin von
swallows im August oder im nächsten
Frühling zu mir nach London einladen ich
will dass sie darüber nachdenkt wer
dafür am besten wäre denn ihr sollt
wissen wer eure Kunden sind verstehen
wie der Markt richtig funktioniert und
allen hier davon berichten wenn ihr
wieder zurück seid
hallo zusammen
[Musik]
wenn sie es erstrangig macht sollte sich
vielleicht Dichter ansetzen
wo kommst
15 kann sie mit uns kommen und uns das
nächste zeigen was sie macht
ich hoffe insgeheim dass People Tree
nicht notwendig wäre und dass wir ein
anderes Handelssystem hätten dass die
Menschenrechte achtet und die Umwelt
respektiert aber je länger ich in der
Entwicklung involviert war und enger mit
gewissen Partnern zusammen arbeitete
desto mehr schreckliche Handelspraktiken
entdeckte ich die alles unterminieren
woran wir und die meisten Menschen
glauben und was wir wertschätzen
People Tree entwickelte sich organisch
aus einer großartigen Gruppe heraus die
fest daran glaubt dass es einen anderen
Weg geben muss wie man arbeitet lebt
konsumiert und mit anderen Menschen auf
humanere Weise interagiert ich hätte nie
gedacht dass People Tree einmal in
tausenden Läden verkauft wird ich sehe
noch so viele Stellen die wir anpacken
müssen und ich denke dass es nicht nur
um das Schaffen von 7000 Arbeitsplätzen
bei People Tree geht sondern auch darum
dass man zu einer Veränderung der
Industrie beiträgt und zeigt dass unser
Geschäftsmodell funktioniert
[Musik]
mit dem biologischen Anbau begannen gab
es damals nur zwei oder drei biopharmer
und wir gründeten die Texas organic
cotton marketing-kooperative die
Vereinbarung war dass sie anbauen und
ich verkaufe ich fing an mit Senatorin
wie Jacob Davids über die
Baumwollpflanzen zu sprechen und alle
sahen uns nur noch an als wären wir
völlig verrückt geworden oft werden
Konsumenten auf Bio-Milch aufmerksam
durch eine ausgebrochene Allergie z.B
aber Baumwolle und andere Stoffe die man
an die Haut lässt alarmiert Sie
interessanterweise nicht und das obwohl
die Haut das größte Organ ist dass wir
haben bei Lebensmitteln ist es einfacher
beim bio-apfel nehme ich keine
Chemikalien und Pestizide auf doch bei
Kleidung wird diese Verbindung nicht
hergestellt darum muss man die Dinge aus
einer entfernteren Perspektive
betrachten es betrifft auch unsere Luft
unseren ganzen Planeten bringt uns
Menschen erst dann bekommt man das
richtige Bewusstsein auch wenn man
erstmal denkt dass man selbst nicht
unmittelbar eingreift durch den Kauf
eines biohemdes doch der Einfluss zeigt
sich im großen Gesamtbild und ganz
besonders an den Orten wo die Baumwolle
angebaut wird
auf den eisigen Frost denn er
entblättert die Pflanzen und wenn wir
dann ernten öffnen sich die Reifen
Kapseln die die Baumwolle beinhalten der
sogenannte Baumwollpflücker der hier
dann drüber fährt heißt so weil er mit
einer Art fingergabel die Baumwolle
tatsächlich pflückt
da hinten kann man diese Maschine sehen
wie sie schon das halbe Feld
eingesammelt hat
[Musik]
ich glaube eines der größten Probleme
des derzeitigen Modells ist dass der
Profit im Mittelpunkt steht und es
berücksichtigt einfach nicht alle Kosten
wie zum Beispiel die Kosten von
Wasserverschmutzung die Kosten von
Arbeitskraft die Kosten für die Gitter
an den Fenstern wenn Menschen in einer
Fabrik sterben wenn ein Feuer ausbricht
die Kosten für Landwirte die keinen
Zugang zu Bildung und Krankenkassen
haben ohne das wissen wir nicht was der
wahre Preis eigentlich ist
liegt am großen Ganges dem heiligsten
aller Flüsse er ist äußerst wichtig für
800 Millionen Hindus und dient als
Lebensader für Nordindien doch dieser
Fluss wird immer stärker verschmutzt und
von den Lederfabriken in canpoor völlig
zerstört den Blüte den Aufgang
durch die stark wachsende Nachfrage nach
billigem Leder wurde kann kurze
Hauptstadt des indischen leder-exports
[Musik]
jeden Tag werden hier über 50 Millionen
Liter giftiges Abwasser aus lokalen
Gerbereien ausgeschieden schwere
Chemikalien die zur Lederverarbeitung
eingesetzt werden wie das chrom-trioxid
gelangen in die lokale Landwirtschaft
und sogar ins Trinkwasser an Orten wie
kann pur fernab der Sichtweite der Welt
können führende westliche Marken billige
Materialien beschaffen und sich aus
aller Verantwortung gegenüber der
ansteigenden Kosten für Gesundheit und
Umwelt entziehen
[Musik]
teppelin der Terrier die Menschen in
dieser Gegend sitzen in der Falle wegen
der gerbereiverschmutzung die ganze
Umgebung ist verschmutzt ebenso Grund
und Boden die einzige Trinkwasserquelle
das Grundwasser ist mit Chrom
kontaminiert landwirtschaftliche
Erzeugnisse wie Salat und Gemüse werden
dort angebaut die Gesundheit der
Menschen ist sehr beeinträchtigt und es
gibt viele verschiedene Hautprobleme wie
Ausschläge Geschwüre Pusteln sogar
Taubheitsgefühle in den Gliedmaßen sie
leiden an Magenerkrankungen
möglicherweise auch an Krebs Boys
bist du
meine Tochter leidet an Gelbsucht fast
in jedem zweiten Haus leidet
irgendjemand an irgendetwas und das wird
von Jahr zu Jahr immer mehr
all unsere Ersparnisse fließen in die
Behandlung dieser Krankheiten weil
dieses aggressive Chrom in unserem
Wasser die Leber direkt angreift
es verursacht Verdauungsprobleme und
viele kriegen davon Gelbsucht oder sogar
Leberkrebs weil sie nicht imstande sind
angemessene Vorkehrungen zu treffen
[Musik]
man kann die besten Materialien in den
Luxusläden in Mailand Paris oder London
finden aber es steckt so viel
unsichtbare Arbeit drin so viele
Chemikalien wurden über Abwässer in die
Flüsse abgeleitet aber wir sehen zu
diesem Zeitpunkt nur das fertige Produkt
wir müssen einen Gang runterschalten und
darüber nachdenken
die Modebranche ist heute die am
zweitstärksten verschmutzende Industrie
der Welt gleich hinter der Ölindustrie
das alarmierende ist nicht nur das Mode
einen gewaltigen Anteil an Ressourcen
aufbraucht und gigantische Auswirkungen
auf die Umwelt hervorruft sondern auch
dass diese Ressourcen und Auswirkungen
meist gar nicht bemessen werden
weil diese Ressourcen so reichlich
vorhanden waren nahmen wir an dass sie
auf ewig ausreichen würden darum hat der
Handel sie nie in die Gleichung mit
einbezogen wir erleben hier erst seit
den 1950er Jahren diese industrielle
Ausdehnung in einem Maße indem wir
exponentielles Wachstum und
exponentielle Verwendung von Ressourcen
sehen
das erste Wirtschaftssystem auf dem
unser Leben basiert ist die
naturwirtschaft diese Wirtschaft ist
zwar riesig wird aber nicht gezählt dann
haben wir die Wirtschaft der Menschen
der arbeitenden Männer und Frauen der
Bauern doch das alles wurde durch dieses
Konstrukt unsichtbar gemacht zuerst in
der Großen Depression und dann während
der Kriegsjahre
die Zahl die als Bruttoinlandsprodukt
bezeichnet wird misst nur das womit
gehandelt wird und das wurde zum neuen
Rohstoffes
viele Ressourcen die wir für unsere
Kleidung verwenden werden gar nicht in
die Produktionskosten mit einberechnet
also die Kosten für das Wasser die
Landflächen zum Anbau der Fasern die
Chemikalien zum Färben lernen
all diese Dinge sind Eingaben und als
Eingaben kosten sie natürlich etwas aber
sie geben auch etwas aus
in manchen Fällen haben sie gute
Ausgaben wie die Kleidung selbst oder
Arbeitsplätze doch in anderen Fällen
geben sie sehr schlechte Dinge aus wie
schädliche Chemikalien oder
Treibhausgase aber auch diese Dinge
haben ihre Kosten
wirst du traurig sein wenn du Nadja
wieder verlassen musst natürlich werde
ich traurig sein aber was soll ich denn
anderes machen mit meinem Job hier bin
ich gezwungen sie im Dorf unterzubringen
sie hat in den letzten zwei Monaten fast
nichts für die Schule gelernt sie sieht
nur fern Trickfilme oder Musikvideos
aber wenn sie im Dorf ist geht das nicht
mehr denn dann geht sie morgens in die
Schule und kommt zum Mittagessen wieder
heim und um drei geht sie dann zum
Privatunterricht das wäre hier unmöglich
und was machst du jetzt mit Nadja
manchmal lasse ich sie bei den Nachbarn
manchmal kümmert sich ihr Vater um sie
und manchmal nehme ich sie mit in die
Fabrik so wie gestern
die selben Niedriglöhne die Bangladesch
zu einem attraktiven Geschäftszentrum
für Marken gemacht haben ließen
Millionen Arbeiter immense Überstunden
ableisten so dass es für viele unmöglich
wurde ihre Kinder bei sich zu behalten
sogar in den schlimmsten Slums
um ihren Kindern eine Ausbildung und die
Chance auf eine bessere Zukunft als in
der Fabriken zu ermöglichen lassen viele
Fabrikarbeiterinnen wie Schima ihre
Kinder bei der Familie oder bei Freunden
in den Dörfern in der Hoffnung sie ein
bis zweimal im Jahr sehen zu können
das ist mein Vater ich habe ihn vor
einem Jahr zuletzt gesehen manchmal
telefonieren wir aber gesehen haben wir
uns vor einem Jahr
und das ist meine Mutter
und auch wir haben uns zuletzt vor einem
Jahr gesehen
wir telefonieren ab und zu aber sehen
uns nur selten
loslassen
[Musik]
die Mühen der Arbeiter in Bangladesch
sind grenzenlos jeden Tag wachen wir
frühmorgens auf gehen in die Fabrik und
arbeiten den ganzen Tag wirklich schwer
und mit all unserer harten Arbeit
stellen wir die Kleidung her Kleidung
die die Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
tragen doch diese Menschen wissen oft
nicht wie schwer es für uns ist diese
Kleidung herzustellen sie kaufen und
tragen Sie nur
ich finde dass diese Kleidung auch mit
unserem Blut produziert wird denn
bereits viele Fabrikarbeiter starben bei
schweren Unfällen so wie letztes Jahr
der fabrikanschluss von Runner Plaza
viele Menschen sind dort ums Leben
gekommen
es ist sehr schmerzhaft für uns und ich
will nicht dass jemand etwas trägt das
mit unserem Blut hergestellt worden ist
wir möchten bessere Arbeitsbedingungen
für uns und dass jeder darauf aufmerksam
wird
ich will keine weiteren Inhaber wie den
von Runner Plaza der so viel riskiert
hat und die Arbeiter unter solchen
Bedingungen zur Arbeit gezwungen hat
ich will das niemand mehr so sterben
muss dass keine Mütter mehr ihre Kinder
auf diese Weise verlieren müssen
ich will dass die Inhaber mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen und mehr auf
uns achten
eigentlich nutzen wir ihr Bedürfnis nach
Arbeit aus um sie als Sklaven zu halten
ich sage nicht dass wir das lassen
sollten nein wir müssen ihnen Arbeit
geben aber sie müssten mit demselben
Respekt behandelt werden mit dem wir
unsere Kinder und Freunde behandeln sie
sind nicht anders als wir denn nur die
fünf frommerce
fordert eine drastische Veränderung in
der Modeindustrie sie machte
Schlagzeilen mit der Green carpet
challenge in dem sie Stars und
Top-Designer dazu aufforderte Teil einer
aufmerksameren modegestaltung zu werden
sie betreibt ein Beratungsunternehmen
für Nachhaltigkeit namens Eco age und
wurde auf eine Konferenz geladen um über
die Zukunft der Mode zu sprechen
wenn es fast fashion nicht gäbe
bräuchten wir kein Treffen in Kopenhagen
um zu versuchen die Zerstörung der
Umwelt und der sozialen Gerechtigkeit
die in den letzten 20 Jahren verursacht
worden ist zu beheben Existenz
möchte schnell produzieren also müssen
die Fabrikarbeiter schneller und
billiger produzieren daher sind die
Fabrikarbeiter das einzige Glied in der
Wertschöpfungskette bei denen die Spanne
gedrückt wird
wir haben diese riesigen Unternehmen die
in den Fabriken von Bangladesch
Auftragsvolumina von 1,5 Millionen Jeans
erteilt jeweils für 30 Cent oder 50 Cent
wie kann man so etwas nicht
aber ist es auch aus Sicht der
Verbraucher wirklich demokratisch ein
T-Shirt für 5 Dollar zu kaufen oder eine
Jeans für 20 Dollar oder ziehen die uns
über den Tisch sie lassen uns glauben
dass wir reich und wohlhabend sind weil
wir uns viel kaufen können aber in
Wirklichkeit machen sie uns nur ärmer
und die einzigen die reicher werden sind
die Inhaber dieser fast fashion Marken
das macht mich etwas ärgerlich
sie haben über die Verpflichtung des
Versuchs und des Versprechens eines
Grundeinkommens gesprochen
was bedeutet das wie definiert man
überhaupt ein faires Existenzminimum in
Bangladesch was heißt das genau ein
Pilotversuch in drei Fabriken zu haben
mit dem Ergebnis das 15% eurer Fabriken
so etwas bis 2018 umsetzen sollen das
ist nicht ausreichend bei weitem nicht
unseres Erachtens sollte die Definition
eines Existenzminimums von den Arbeitern
kommen und das sollte in unsere
Arbeitsweise integriert werden und wie
hoch sollte es sein uns steht es nicht
zu eine Höhe zu beziffern aber wir
machen regelmäßig Schätze noch mal wie
hoch ist das ist die Grundbedürfnisse
der arbeiterdecken
h&M hat das Modell der fast fashion
perfektioniert und ist heute der
zweitgrößte bekleidungskonzern der
Geschichte mit einem jährlichen Umsatz
von fast 18 Milliarden US-Dollar sie
sind einer der größten
Bekleidungshersteller sowohl in
Bangladesch als auch in Kambodscha
leider haben sie wie auch alle anderen
großen Händler die ich gefragt habe alle
Interviewfragen für diesen Film
abgelehnt
in Kambodscha hatten die Fabrikarbeiter
irgendwann genug und sind vor kurzem auf
die Straße und für eine Erhöhung des
Mindestlohns zu streiken
doch als die Proteste weiter anhielten
wurden die Arbeiter und Arbeiterinnen
auf brutale Weise zurückgedrängt und die
Polizei eröffnete sogar das Feuer auf
sie mit scharfer Munition
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine Frau kam bei den Zusammenstößen
zwischen textilfabrikarbeitern und der
Polizei in Kambodscha ums Leben viele
wurden verletzt
[Musik]
zwei Tage lang war Kambodscha ein
einziges Schlachtfeld
vor allem die Hauptstadt pompen
Polizei und Fallschirmjäger rückten an
als ob es einen Bürgerkrieg gäbe
und warum weil die Arbeiter der
Textilindustrie auf einen Mindestlohn
von 160 Dollar behalten
[Musik]
die Regierung ging mit aller Härte gegen
uns vor und dabei wurden fünf Arbeiter
getötet 23 verhaftet und über 40
verletzt dabei verlangen wir doch
überhaupt nicht viel Geld wir möchten
doch auch nur einen angemessenen Lohn um
ein anständiges und würdevolles Leben zu
führen doch der Regierung ist es egal
wie arm wir sind oder wie sehr wir schon
gelitten haben die Arbeiter sind denen
völlig egal und daher verlangen wir
weiterhin einen Mindestlohn von 160
Dollar im Monat
ist die funeral auf heute ist das
Begräbnis eines fabrikarbeiters der zu
Tode geprügelt worden ist er hatte vor
seinem Tod heute Morgen sehr schwer
gelitten wie vor hieß das morning
dabei hat er nichts Falsches getan
er und seine Arbeitskollegen wollten nur
bessere Lebensbedingungen
[Musik]
wir werden diesen Kampf weiterführen so
dass alle kambodschanischen Arbeiter
irgendwann angemessener Arbeit
Bedingungen bekommen werden
danke schön
[Musik]
die kambodschanische Regierung sowie die
anderen Entwicklungsländer Trachten
verzweifelt nach den Geschäften mit den
multinationalen Konzernen wegen der
ständigen Bedrohung dass diese Marken
ihre Produktionen in andere Länder
verlagern könnten drückt die Regierung
einerseits die Löhne und übergeht
andererseits regelmäßig das Arbeitsrecht
aber weil die großmarken ihre Arbeiter
nicht offiziell einstellen bzw die
Fabriken nicht deren Eigentum sind sind
Sie in der Lage gigantische Profite
einzufahren und gleichzeitig keinerlei
Verantwortung für die Armutslöhne Fabrik
Unglücke und permanente gewaltsame
Behandlung der Arbeiter zu übernehmen
das ganze System fühlt sich langsam an
wie ein perfekt konstruierter Albtraum
in dem die Arbeiter gefangen sind
man kann uns nicht täuschen uns unsere
Arbeitskraft berauben und auch noch
unsere Arbeiter Ausbeuten sie werden
ihren Kampf weiterführen
ich rufe die internationalen Marken dazu
auf unserem täglichen Kampf in Dollars
in Pfund in Euros aufzuwiegen
es rechnet sich unmittelbar um in
menschliches Kapital und soziale
Verantwortung dieser Großkonzerne
und es verwandelt sich in
wirtschaftliche Gerechtigkeit wenn sich
alles nur noch auf die Profit
Generierung für die Konzerne
konzentriert sieht man wie die
Menschenrechte Umwelt und Arbeitsrechte
allesamt verloren gehen man sieht dass
die Arbeiter immer stärker ausgebeutet
werden weil die Preise ständig
runtergedrückt werden und das alles nur
um diesen Impuls nach mehr
kapitalanhäufung zu befriedigen das ist
zu tiefst problematisch weil es zur
Massen Verelendung von hunderten
Millionen Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
führt
wenn man solche Firmen anschreibt
schicken sie dir ihren Verhaltenskodex
zu und er ist immer wunderschön
formuliert mit Dingen wie wir übernehmen
Verantwortung für die Bedingungen unter
denen unsere Produkte hergestellt werden
wir erwarten von allen Fabriken die wir
beauftragen dass sie die
mindestlohngesetze einhalten die
Landesgesetze einhalten die Frauen
respektieren keine Kinder einstellen
keine Zwangsarbeit einsetzen keine
exzessiven Überstunden und so weiter
doch als wir den Kongress vor ein paar
Jahren einen Gesetzesentwurf vorlegten
den wir Gesetz für angemessene
Arbeitskonditionen und fairen Wettbewerb
nannten antworteten alle Konzerne
einstimmig um Gottes Willen das wäre ja
ein Hindernis für den freien Handel wir
dürfen keine Regulierungen haben das
geht doch nicht
sie möchten es partout bei freiwilligen
Verhaltensnormen belassen ich meine sie
haben auch darum gekämpft und rechte
gewonnen die ihre Dinge und Interessen
konkret schützen aber was ist mit den
Arbeitern die bleiben auf freiwilligen
verhaltensgrundsätzen sitzen und was wir
in immer mehr Fällen beobachten ist dass
diese freiwilligen Grundsätze nicht
einmal das Papierwerk sind auf dem sie
stehen
wir müssen besonders in der
Modeindustrie anerkennen dass
Humankapital einer erheblicher Teil
dieser wundersamen Formel ist ohne das
human-kapital ohne billige besonders
weibliche Arbeitskraft würde es solche
Profite gar nicht erst geben das muss
endlich anerkannt werden und es muss
eine Auseinandersetzung stattfinden dass
diese Menschen entlohnt und nicht
ausgebeutet werden was ist deren Anteil
das sollte eine ständige zentrale Frage
sein
sind diese Käufer unmoralisch oder sind
sie einfach nur amoralisch das System
für das sie arbeiten und das System das
Firmen so etwas erlaubt ist amoralisch
die betroffenen Individuen sind einfach
nur ein Produkt dieses Systems was wir
tun müssen ist das Verhalten dieser
Firmen zu ändern
in einem System das nur Gewinne bemisst
haben Firmen wenig Anreiz etwas anderes
zu tun als den Umsatz im nächsten
Quartal zu steigern
ganz gleich welche Schäden dabei
verursacht werden
sowohl Konzerne aus der Textil als auch
aus der Chemieindustrie und der
Landwirtschaft wachsen heutzutage zu
noch nie dagewesenen Größen und
machtordnungen heran diese oberste
Direktive der Gewinnmaximierung um jeden
Preis steht im direkten Gegensatz zu
unseren Werten
Richard Wolf ein Ökonom der seine
Abschlüsse in Harvard Stanford und Yale
absolviert hat ist davon überzeugt dass
das wahre Problem im System selbst liegt
so Amerika ist zu einem äußersten
befremdenden Land geworden man darf das
Bildungssystem kritisieren um die
Schulen zu verbessern oder das
Transportsystem um die Infrastrukturen
zu verbessern aber das Wirtschaftssystem
darf man nicht kritisieren es hat quasi
einen Freischein man darf es einfach
nicht und wenn man etwas seit 50 Jahren
nicht mehr hinterfragt fängt das an zu
schimmeln eine gesunde Gesellschaft kann
nur dann richtig funktionieren wenn sich
alle Systemkomponenten der Kritik
unterziehen lassen damit wir sie
diskutieren können um sie wieder zu
richten oder zu verbessern der
Kapitalismus aber durfte nicht
hinterfragt werden
der Kapitalismus ist der Grund wieso die
Modeindustrie heute so ist darum haben
arbeite ein langer Tisch einen so
niedrigen Lohn denn wenn man in einem
kapitalistischen System arbeitet ist das
wichtigste Gewinne zu machen und zwar
immer mehr als Konkurrenz das spornt die
Konzerne an die Löhne noch weiter zu
drücken
companies
und die ganzen Modemarken gehen nur aus
einem einzigen Grund an Orte wie
Bangladesch nämlich immer nur um die
billigste Arbeitskraft zu bekommen
Bangladesch hat keine festen Tarife
keine Gewerkschaften einen extrem
niedrigen Mindestlohn kann Mutterschutz
keine Rentenkassen darum sitzt die
Modeindustrie in Bangladesch weil es die
größten Profite aus diesen Menschen
herausholen kann
bevor man ein Problem lösen kann muss
man erst eingestehen dass es eines gibt
und bevor wir ein Wirtschaftssystem
reparieren können das auf diese Weise
agiert und solche Spannungen
Ungleichheiten und Aufregung in unserer
Gesellschaft produziert müssen wir das
wahre Ausmaß des Problems erst einmal
erkennen und das ist das System als
Ganzes erst dann sollte eine nationale
Debatte gestartet werden in der wir
lange und tiefgründig über besser gut
funktionierende alternativsysteme
nachdenken für den Farmen die größte
Bedrohung für die Umwelt ist dass das
Kapital unendlich expandieren muss um zu
überleben es darf keine Grenzen in
Ausbreitung und Wachstum haben die
natürliche Welt hat logischerweise
Grenzen die ganz klar definieren wie
viel der Planet ertragen kann bezüglich
Produktion Handel Transport und
Distribution es ist ziemlich
offensichtlich dass wir viele dieser
Grenzen bereits überschritten haben
weswegen wir im Moment solchen Stress in
der natürlichen Welt erleben
das System in dem wir leben entspricht
überhaupt nicht den Vorstellungen der
meisten Menschen ich denke es macht die
meisten Menschen sehr unglücklich und
ich denke nicht dass Menschen auf einem
langsam da Hinsicht in den Planeten
leben oder von Ihrem Nachbarn
ausgebeutet werden wollen ich glaube wir
brauchen einen gewaltigen systemischen
Wandel wenn man das System nicht
verändert hält man die
Entscheidungsgewalt dieser Konzerne
intakt das bedeutet dass eine kleine
Gruppe von Führungskräften und
Aktionären weiterhin im selben System
arbeiten werden das abhängig ist von
denselben Formen von Zuckerbrot und
Peitsche und sie früher oder später dazu
bringen wird irgendwo dieselben
Bedingungen wieder zu schaffen gegen die
wir jetzt anzukämpfen versuchen man muss
aufhören zu versuchen die Bedingungen zu
verbessern und anfangen etwas am System
zu unternehmen sonst meint man es nicht
ernst
unser Wirtschaftssystem ist der
Konsumkapitalismus deswegen braucht die
Regierung einen sehr hohen Konsumismus
natürlich machen die Konzerne damit und
deswegen fangen die Menschen irgendwann
auch damit an die meisten mit denen ich
darüber gesprochen habe entgegnen mir
dann aber wenn wir den Materialismus
zurückschrauben wird die Wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen
nun das stimmt natürlich bis zu einem
gewissen Grad weil unsere Wirtschaft auf
materialistischen Werten fundiert das
ist Teil ihres Antriebs um zu überleben
das Problem ist nur dass ein wirklich
hoher Preis dafür bezahlt wird
findet mal wieder heute Abend in den
amerikanischen Kaufhäusern statt
mancherorts erscheint es als ob jemand
bekannt gegeben hätte dass die Bestände
für immer ausgehen könnten und man
besser alles stehen und liegen lassen
sollte
Walmart machte über 10 Millionen
Transaktionen in den ersten vier Stunden
ein neuer kundenrekord 15.000 Menschen
im New Yorker Messis der schwarze
Freitag ist der stärkste Tag im ganzen
Jahr für den Einzelhandel und hier bei
maisies machen wir so viel Umsatz an
diesem Tag wie an keinem anderen im Jahr
diese weihnachtsbummelorg dir beweist
dass Amerika wieder zurück ist wir sind
wieder vereint oh ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir geben wieder Geld aus dass wir nicht
haben für Dinge die wir nicht brauchen
um sie Menschen zu schenken die wir
nicht mögen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Kleinen sehr und sie können besser
auf sie aufpassen als ich es kann aber
eins macht mich doch traurig unabhängig
davon wie sehr es geliebt wird kann
keiner ein Kind so sehr lieben wie die
eigenen Eltern ich bin tot unglücklich
[Musik]
ich will nicht dass meine Tochter so wie
ich in einer Textilfabrik arbeiten muss
ich mache mir Sorgen aber eines Tages
werde ich wieder glücklicher sein wenn
ich weiß dass sie eine bessere Zukunft
hat
sie wird ein guter Mensch und die Leute
werden sagen dass ihre Mutter ihr eine
gute Ausbildung und Erziehung ermöglicht
hat und das obwohl sie in einer
Textilfabrik in darke arbeitete weit weg
von ihrer Tochter
Mannes gehört
wenn sie Beamten wird oder einen guten
Mann heiratet werden die Menschen wissen
dass ich sehr stolz bin und dass ich
darum gekämpft und mein Bestes versucht
habe damit sie nicht dasselbe
durchstehen musste wie ich dass ich sie
gut erzogen habe
[Musik]
ich wuchs auf einer Farm auf habe einen
Mann geheiratet der auch auf einer Farm
aufgewachsen war und wir lebten auf
einer Farm natürlich legten wir viel
Wert auf Sicherheit doch diese
neuartigen Chemikalien und die
Intensität in der sie angewendet wurden
stiegen stetig an dann im Jahr 2005 fing
Carrie an einige feinmotorische
Fähigkeiten zu verlieren bis wir
herausfanden dass er glioblastoma
multiforme hatte einen Hirntumor vierten
Grades in der Blütezeit seines Lebens
mit sieben und 40 er starb schließlich
mit 50 obwohl die Ärzte ihm nur noch
sechs Monate gegeben
[Musik]
hat riesige krebskliniken und
medizinische Zentren darum mussten wir
für die Operation zum Glück nicht
woanders hin wir konnten auch deswegen
hier bleiben weil der Chirurg so viele
dieser Tumore behandelte er sagte uns
dass diese Art überwiegend bei Männern
im Alter zwischen 45 und 65 Auftritt die
in der Landwirtschaft oder in der
Ölindustrie tätig sind leider habe ich
keinen eindeutigen Beweis oder einen
Bluttest der aufzeigt dass die Nutzung
von Baumwoll und Agrarchemikalien
unmittelbar zum Tod meines Mannes
geführt hat obwohl es auch viele
ähnliche Verknüpfungen mit dem Tod
seines Vaters gibt wir wuchsen auf
chemieintensiven Farmen auf und legten
inmitten von 3,6 Millionen Quadratmetern
Acker die viele Pestizide benötigten zu
diesem Zeitpunkt wurde Bioanbau nicht
mehr nur wichtig für mich sondern
zwingend notwendig es ist auch zwingend
notwendig dass wir die Landwirtschaft
verändern und dass wir wenn wir von
langfristiger Nachhaltigkeit und dem
Wohl unseres Lebens und das unserer
Kinder sprechen auch uns verändern
müssen
[Musik]
das ist der Beginn einer Kehrtwende und
zwar nicht nur um Mode auf
verantwortungsvollere Weise zu machen
sondern um die Formen des Kapitalismus
und die des Wirtschaftens zu erneuern
ich bin mir sicher dass wir eine
signifikante Veränderung in den
kommenden zehn Jahren erleben werden ob
sie noch rechtzeitig geschieht ist eine
andere Frage
Brooklyn das was Amerika bräuchte wäre
eine Revolution der Werte es müsse
aufhören Menschen wie Gegenstände zu
behandeln und damit aufhören Profite
über die Menschen zu stellen um
stattdessen Menschen mit diesen
Propheten auf humane Weise zu behandeln
bei Gott wir könnten es doch viel besser
lösen wenn wir wollen und zwar wenn wir
die Industrie wie ich es immer fordere
auf der Welt verteilen würden anstatt
sie an einem Zentrum zu konzentrieren
lass uns doch auch den Nutzen
globalisiert teilen und zwar auf
ordnungsgemäße adäquater und
sorgfältiger Weise
wir müssen erkennen Kapital nur Geld ist
und Geld ein Zweckmittel die Menschen
sollten dafür verantwortlich gemacht
werden wieder mit umgegangen wird und
wir müssen die Schöpfungskraft der
Menschen würdigen und anfangen von
Kreativität zu sprechen anstelle von
Arbeit
nicht als eine wahre ansehen mit der
spekuliert oder gehandelt werden kann
sondern als die Lebensgrundlage von uns
allen
wir müssen alle Verbraucher in
Aktivisten verwandeln die moralische
Fragen stellen und zwar ganz einfache
Fragen zum Beispiel über die Herkunft
der Kleidung sie müssen für sich sagen
dass es ihn akzeptabel ist wenn jemand
an seinem Arbeitsplatz sterben muss wir
können sie doch nicht einfach machen
lassen was sie wollen es hat zu viele
globale negative Auswirkungen auf
Millionen von Menschen und auf
gemeinsame Rohstoffe world
werden wir weiterhin das Glück im Konsum
von Dingen suchen
werden wir uns weiterhin mit einem
System zufriedengeben dass uns nur reich
fühlen lässt während wir diese Welt für
unsere Nachkommen Arm hinterlassen
werden wir weiterhin über jene Leben
einfach hinwegsehen die unsere Kleidung
erst ermöglichen oder wird dies ein
Wendepunkt sein ein neues Kapitel in
unsere Geschichte in dem wir gemeinsam
eine wirkliche Veränderung bewirken
indem wir uns bewusst machen dass alles
was wir tragen aus Menschenhand
entstanden ist
inmitten all dieser Herausforderungen
und all der Probleme die uns vollkommen
ohnmächtig fühlen lassen könnten wir
vielleicht hiermit anfangen unsere
Kleidung
[Musik]
[Applaus]